France 24 et Public Sénat présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bonjour et bienvenue
merci de nous rejoindre aujourd'hui nous
recevons une figure du gouvernement
portugais par extension un homme qui a
su assumer une voix une voix une vision
différente parfois pour permettre et
bien à la diplomatie portugaise de se
faire une place en tout cas de se faire
entendre au sein de l'Union européenne
notre invité est un diplomate ancien
secrétaire d'État aux Affaires
étrangères et à la coopération ancien
ministre de la Défense aussi ancien
ambassadeur européen en Inde et au
Brésil je vais au gommage gravigno
ministre des Affaires étrangères
portugais et notre grand invité je vois
gommage cravignon bonjour Merci pour
l'invitation
vous êtes ministre des Affaires
étrangères portugais depuis un peu plus
d'un an et par conséquent exercer vos
fonctions c'est peut-être confronté à un
conflit le conflit en Ukraine est
confronté aussi aux limites de l'Union
européenne dans bien des domaines est-ce
que pour vous l'Union est à la hauteur
de ce conflit il y a eu un changement
énorme de la position de la capacité de
la européenne
pendant les dernières années nous avons
quand même sur avoir
rester avec une unité absolument
improbable et je suis très fier alors
onzième paquet de sanctions seraient en
cours d'études est-ce que ben alors on
va on va y aller assez frontalement
est-ce que comme dirait Guy vero stade
sur nos antennes il y a quelques
semaines est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas aux
limites de l'exercice à force de
proposer des sanctions progressives et
d'en garder sous le coup de sous le pied
est-ce que ces sanctions elles ont
encore alors je dirais pas encore un
sens mais encore une efficacité je pense
que les l'impact des sanctions est très
réel et ça se fait sentir sur la
capacité
industrielle militaire et industriel de
la Russie et ça va se faire sentir
pendant longtemps c'est à dire c'est un
erreur profond pour la Russie tout ce
qui est tout l'édition décision la prise
une notamment de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
parce que les conséquences économiques
vont vont être terribles et vont rester
là pour pour décennies maintenant je
pense que on dit parfois que les
sentiments n'ont pas les résultats dans
un
que la guerre a continué malgré les
sanctions bien sûr les sanctions sont un
instrument sont inutiles non militaires
non violent pour impressionner et la
pression est très réelle alors si la
Russie n'est peut-être pas si étouffée
que ça c'est peut-être en raison de la
constitution d'un nouvel axe d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dénoncé des pays qui
semblaient des la Russie la Chine les
Émirats arabes unis l'Iran avec ce
conflit est-ce que on assiste à un
retour des blocs est-ce que ça complique
pas un peu la manœuvre tout simplement
je pense pas exactement un retour bloc
on est en train de voir la construction
d'une constellation complètement
différente et les pays que vous avez
mentionnés spécialement la Chine qui a
des grandes ambitions pour l'avenir
nous veulent pas être mise dans un dans
une situation
où la Russie la guerre de la Russie a
choisi de faire et l'aspect dominant de
la scène internationale oui il y en a
plusieurs pays qui veulent aider la
Russie à sortir de cette situation a
trouvé une future un futur pour pour
lui-même mais c'est pas le futur imaginé
par Monsieur lavrove un futur eu la
Russie aura
brillant une étoile brillante dans une
constellation de pays
antioxydants non cela est vraiment pas
très probable alors on va y revenir mais
la Chine aujourd'hui se pose en faiseur
de paix comment on se positionne
aujourd'hui en tant qu'Européen vous
vous dites finalement toutes les
solutions sont sont bonnes à prendre ou
alors vous faites partie plutôt de la
famille des sceptique
bon malheureusement il n'y a pas de
raison pour grande optimisme à ce moment
mais c'est bien que finalement le
président chez une Ping a parlé avec
Président zellenski c'est dommage que
cela a pris 15 mois mais c'est important
que la Chine qui a un dialogue très
intense avec la Russie qu'elle parle
aussi avec l'Ukraine qu'elle comprenne
et je pense que c'est aussi un message
qui est envoyé à
Moscou et je soulignais votre franc
parler tout à l'heure vous avez
vous-même affirmé que la Chine jouait
les équilibristes dans ce conflit est-ce
que finalement on n'y est pas là non on
n'est pas là on n'est pas là
malheureusement mais la Chine doit être
conscient qu'elle peut jouer un rôle
positif notamment envers la Russie c'est
à dire en expliquant au Russe qu'il faut
absolument trouver une solution sortie
pour la crise qu'elle a crié alors je
vous questionne à ce propos car ces
dernières semaines la question elle
s'est posée avec l'un de vos visiteurs
je veux parler du nouveau président
brésilien Lula de retour après 7 ans de
froid entre vos deux pays où là qui lui
aussi souhaite se poser en médiateur
pour régler le conflit avec quelques
fois des phrases qui ont pu ne pas être
très bien compris ni accepté d'ailleurs
en Ukraine notamment quand Lula a
notamment déclaré avant de partir pour
la Chine que pour un règlement du
conflit l'Ukraine aurait peut-être à
abandonné la Crimée elle a encore levée
de de bouclier comment en fait on réagit
à ça bon d'abord on doit donner la
bienvenue pays comme le Brésil l'Inde la
Chine quand elle se montre inquiète de
la situation
provoquée par la Russie c'est-à-dire on
comprend que ce n'est pas seulement une
guerre européenne c'est une guerre avec
des conséquences mondiales et alors
c'est normal que des grands pays
s'intéressent et c'est de trouver des
solutions malheureusement
on n'est pas là encore on n'a pas encore
les conditions pour pour une médiation
par qui que ce soit mais c'est très bon
que le Brésil et prix initiative d'être
devenu en Europe donc commençons par le
Portugal passant par Espagne de
s'engager avec d'autres pays sur cette
question qui est une question une
question très inquiétante pour tout le
monde
tout à l'heure lors de sa visite chez
vous Lula a fait réagir quand il parle
de Thor partagé dans le conflit c'est
applaudi parmi les affaires étrangères
sergueil lavrof le président de votre
pays Marcello rébello de Sousa a tenu
lui à recadrer alors il a présenté ses
excuses sur l'esclavage ça c'était un
autre aspect de son intervention il a
rappelé tout de même et bien que en fait
le Portugal n'était pas d'accord avec
cette position de Lula oui bien sûr
c'est normal on doit considérer très
normal un pays dans un autre continent
un géant de la géopolitique mais avec
une conscience complètement différente
le Brésil n'a pas eu de guerre sur ces
frontières en siècle et demi alors c'est
normal que le Brésil est une politique
extérieure différente de la politique
extérieure européenne cela dit nous
avons réussi à voir une déclaration
conjointe paragraphe sur le crâne où on
affirme une façon très nette très claire
les grands principes l'intégrité
territoriale condamnation de l'invasion
alors je pense que on fait des progrès
et cela fait partie aussi de du
processus de réintégration du Brésil
dans les grands débats internationales
le Brésil a été absent comme vous le
savez alors comment on dépasse justement
ces désaccord parce que vu de loin et
pour beaucoup au sein même de votre pays
le Brésil sur l'Ukraine a l'air plus
proche de la Russie et de la Chine que
de certains
occidentaux alors on sait le Brésil fait
partie de de de ce qu'on appelle les
briques ces pays émergents qui
regroupent bien le Brésil et l'Inde vous
y avez en tant que diplomate les briques
c'est aussi l'Afrique du Sud c'est aussi
la Chine et la Russie est-ce que
concrètement et bien on a les mêmes
visions est-ce qu'elles sont compatibles
non les mêmes visions non c'est normal
qu'on est des visions différentes on
doit pas dramatiser dans la dans la
politique internationale c'est le plus
fréquent qu'il y ait une diversité des
points de vue le plus important c'est
que on s'entende sur comment chacun peut
contribuer à arriver à la paix que c'est
l'objectif que tous Louis long mais je
le souligne et c'est dans notre
déclaration conjointe une paix juste
c'est à dire une paix qui respecte les
conformes au grand principe de du droit
international on a évoqué la Chine le
sujet de Taïwan va revenir il est encore
très présent lui aussi des députés
Portugais étaient à Taïwan il y a pas
longtemps Taïwan a publiquement év
décidé d'un rapprochement avec le
Portugal vous y êtes favorable alors
vous pensez que l'Union ne doit pas se
laisser engager dans un conflit comme
celui-ci en ce qui concerne les
relations entre l'Europe en général et
la Chine et le Taïwan il faut être il
faut avoir la conscience que le futur
n'est pas écrit c'est à dire on n'est
pas condamné à une situation de conflits
imminent d'invasion par de Taïwan par
par la Chine de bipolarité entre
États-Unis et Chine on est tous là n'a
pas encore été écrit dans les étoiles
c'est à nous de trouver d'autres
solutions alors l'engagement
avec Beijing avec Taïwan et très
important pour l'Europe il faut que nous
soyons présents il faut que nous soyons
dialoguant et il faut que nous ayons la
capacité de chercher un autre futur un
futur différent alors Taiwan c'est
intéressant parce que Lille fait face
aux principes chinois et aux ambiguïté
aussi d'une nation de système la Chine
veut revenir dessus et intégrer Taïwan
dans la région dans d'autres îles Hong
Kong mais aussi Macao ont un statut
spécial Mako une longue histoire avec le
Portugal avant sa rétro session en 99 un
pays de système c'est ce qui est censé
régir les relations entre Macao et Pékin
au moins jusqu'en 2049 est-ce que bah
finalement la crise avec Taïwan dans ces
conditions ça vous inquiète bien sûr que
tout le contexte international nous
inquiète il y a une tension croissante
mais en même temps nous avons patrimoine
de d'une vingtaine 25 ans
assez bien réussi je ne dirais pas du
tout parfait et il faut travailler sur
les les aspects qui ne sont pas
satisfables mais nous avons patrimoine
de confiance qui a été construit et
cela nous donne une excellente de base
de travail pour travailler justement sur
les thèmes qu'il faut améliorer Joseph
Borel mettait en avant la possibilité
d'envoyer des bateaux le Portugal a
choisi de mettre régulièrement en avant
sa volonté d'être plus présent auprès de
l'OTAN on l'a vu avec la fourniture des
chars léopards en
Ukraine mais aussi avec des manœuvres
communes avec le petit dernier de la
famille si je puis me permettre la
Finlande
Esco pour vous l'avenir de la défense
européenne passe toujours et encore par
l'OTAN et dans ce cadre là comment on
invente une défense européenne je parle
à l'ancien ministre de la Défense oui
oui et à faire l'étranger c'est-à-dire
nous avons ici un champ où tous les deux
le champ militaire et sécuritaire doit
se mêler avec nos visions géopolitiques
mais il me semble que une l'autonomie
stratégique de l'Union européenne est
très très importante cela peut se faire
peut se faire en complémentarité avec
l'OTAN il n'y a pas de contradiction
nécessaire il peut avoir des
contradictions mais là il faut les
éviter et qu'il y ait des il y a des
missions qui seront toujours des
missions plus européen que mission de
l'OTAN je pense par exemple à tout ce
qui se passe sur le continent africain
le continent les parties plus proches de
l'Europe les parties plus lointaines qui
me semblent qui ne sont pas vraiment des
régions qui intéressent à l'OTAN en tant
que tel mais qui sont des régions
fondamentales fondamentaux pour l'Europe
étrangères portugais ou la plaidait chez
vous puis en Espagne pour la
résurrection de l'accord UE Mercosur
un accord international signé en 2019
entre les 27 et les pays de la zone à
savoir le Brésil de l'Argentine le
Paraguay et l'Uruguay mais beaucoup au
sein de l'Union décrypte cet accord
comme bien des favorable à l'Union
européenne on a vu notamment et bien
qu'on a apporté des produits agricoles
qui ne respectent pas forcément les
normes européennes on parle là des
pesticides c'est pour beaucoup une
question de distorsion de compétitivité
on mais c'est aussi un problème de
réchauffement climatique à terme le
Portugal a des records de chaleur
récemment c'est des questions de santé
publique aussi et d'environnement est-ce
que là-dessus l'Europe a moyen de
changer un petit peu la boussole et de
hausser le ton
oui il me semble que il y a sur cette
question de la discussion de la
finalisation après une vingtaine
d'années de négociations de la Réunion
européenne merco il y a trois niveaux
qu'il faut pas mêler il faut penser
chaque niveau de votre lieu bien ouverts
d'abord les niveaux des discussions
commerciales stricte c'est-à-dire
question agricoles merci les questions
industrielles et m'aide a été une voix
toujours été une voie très favorable à
l'accord puis il y a un autre mais là je
pense qu'on est on a déjà arrivé un
consensus sur sur les différents points
qui doivent être présents puis il y a le
niveau changement climatique bien sûr
qu'il faut engager
le Brésil et le pays de merco bien sûr
que cela doit être fait dans le contexte
aussi de les désaccord commerciaux comme
on l'a fait avec d'autres pays mais
étant conscient qu'on ne peut pas
introduire de sanctions on peut pas
aller au-delà de de ce qui a été accordé
à Paris et troisièmement très très
important l'Europe veut être un acteur
géopolitique il faut alors que l'Europe
sèche utilisée son utile plus important
le plus peut être le plus efficace
l'utile commercial pour renforcer les
liens avec d'autres régions du monde et
notamment avec un région du monde en
Amérique du Sud qui est très très
compatible avec les grandes valeurs
européens l'entrée du Portugal dans
l'Union européenne c'était en 86 le
nombre d'États membres était à 12
j'imagine que vous vous en rappelez
aujourd'hui on est à 27 on vote pour les
élections européennes désormais dans
dans un an l'Europe est régulièrement
contestée en ce moment est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous diriez finalement aux
gens qui disent bah non j'ai j'ai plus
envie de voter est-ce que l'Europe
finalement c'est toujours la réponse
l'Europe est une réponse absolument
nécessaire
cela dit il y a une un écart très grand
entre les citoyens et les décisions
européennes on sent et les gens sont
assez sensibles à cela il faut pas le
nier et nous avons un défi énorme de
rendre l'Europe plus proche des citoyens
c'est un défi qui se pose au Portugal
c'est un défi qui se pose un peu partout
et il faut absolument éviter que ce défi
se transforment en désillusion avec
l'Europe parce que la réalité est
différente on peut bien avoir une on a
besoin de l'Europe et on peut bien en
avoir une Europe plus proche des
citoyens très bien merci beaucoup je
rigoleche cravignon ministre des
Affaires étrangères du Portugal merci à
vous d'avoir répondu à nos questions
dans notre deuxième partie d'ici
l'Europe et bien on retrouvera
naturellement Caroline de Camaret Karine
de Camaret pour notre débat depuis
Bruxelles il y sera question de santé
alimentaire et du nutriscor
[Musique]
bienvenue à Bruxelles pour nous pencher
sur le contenu de nos assiettes et des
rayons de nos supermarchés l'Europe nous
protège-t-elle contre la malbouffe qui
nuit à notre santé c'était en tout cas
la fonction du nutri-score avec des
petites pastilles allant du vert au
rouge assorti des lettres art AAE
permettant d'évaluer la teneur des
aliments en bons nutriments les
protéines et les fibres ou en mauvais
les sucres les selles et les acides gras
le nutriscor a à la française faisait
initialement figure de favoris pour être
étendu à l'ensemble des 27 mais pour
l'instant et bien ce classement est
réservé à six pays dans l'Union
européenne la France l'Allemagne
l'Espagne la Belgique les Pays-Bas et le
Luxembourg il ne sera d'ailleurs pas
étendu au niveau européen comme c'était
prévu initialement en 2022 dans la
stratégie de la Commission de la ferme à
la fourchette l'Italie et d'autres pays
bloquent cette étiquetage au nom de la
gastronomie et pour la défense de
l'industrie alimentaire lancée en 2017
le nutriscore a aussi fait l'objet de
critiques de ces supporters sur son
caractère un peu obsolète et donc les
algorithmes ont été adaptés pour en
débattre aujourd'hui 2 euros députés
alors Marco Campo menosi bonjour
bienvenue du groupe
identité démocratie de la Ligue en
Italie qui est tout pouvoir en effet
avec Georgia Meloni et qui bloque on le
disait le nutriscor et puis face à vous
Michel rivazy élu des vers françaises
cette fois-ci qui a signé une pétition à
l'égard de la Commission européenne la
plan à l'affichage d'ailleurs au devant
de chacun des des produits de ce
nutriscore
il y a aussi une organisation fa
d'ailleurs qui représente 30 000
professionnels de santé qui a demandé à
la Commission 7 étiquetage parce que la
moitié des adultes dans l'Union
européenne sont en surpoids ça
changerait quelque chose ah oui ça
change quelque chose parce que pourquoi
on veut mettre cette étiquetage c'est
que on s'aperçoit comme vous l'avez
indiqué qu'il y a une obésité ou des
surpoids un adulte sur deux et même
maintenant ça touche les enfants alors
pourquoi ça parce que souvent les
aliments sont trop gras trop sucrés trop
salés et cette étiquetage permet
justement aux consommateurs de choisir
des aliments qui le sont moins et ce qui
est intéressant dans nutri-score c'est
que ça s'appuie sur plein d'études
scientifiques voyez c'est pas un
algorithme qui sort de je sais pas où
c'est on tient compte de la nature du
produit et on le classe et moi si je
veux acheter par exemple des biscuits
pour mes enfants parce que ça touche que
les produits vous voyez une même
catégorie de produits et si je veux des
biscuits je vais choisir des biscuits
avec le label a plutôt que le C ou le D
ou le E parce que ça voudra dire qu'il y
a trop de sel ou trop de de sucre et ça
une importance c'est pour ça que
vraiment je voudrais vous sensibiliser
là-dessus c'est que qui est contre ben
c'est le lobby agroalimentaire qui est
contre parce que ça remet en cause leurs
recettes alors que si tous les
consommateurs vont vers le a le B ou le
C et bien ils sont obligés de changer
leurs recettes de cuisine sur les
produits pour qu'il y ait moins de sel
moins de sucre moins de gras mais vous
en Italie vous vous y opposez parce que
vous dites ça met en cause finalement
votre cuisine italienne
parce que selon nous ça banalise le
débat parce que il faut bien informer
les consommateurs mais mais avec un feu
rouge sur des produits dans la route en
feu rouge ça signifie arrête-toi tu ne
peux pas passer et alors ça c'est une
chose qui que nous pensons n'est pas
balancé considéré
des produits alimentaires c'est pas
c'est pas suffisant l'Italie a proposé
des alternatives avec un système
peut-être un peu complexe des bactéries
je sais très bien mais mais attention il
faut bien considérer que l'industrie de
l'alimentation qui peut jouer un peu
avec la Camille
peut avoir des des effets positifs parce
que il peut jouer avec la Camille pour
avoir des notes notre escort meilleur et
le problème c'est pour les producteurs
traditionnels et un autre problème selon
moi selon nous c'est aussi comme on
considère le consommateur parce que
parce que avec une banalisation de la
communication
c'est comme au niveau du register on
pense que le consommateur ne peut pas
paraître des décisions chacun connaît
très bien que on peut pas consommer
beaucoup de fromages beaucoup de choses
la même chose il y a eu un Irlande avec
l'alcool
c'est un approche que nous ne partageons
pas la respons
abilisateur on peut lire les étiquettes
etc vous n'y croyez pas finalement c'est
vrai que ce rouge il tape un peu dans
l'oeil ça veut dire interdit c'est pas
une interdiction le rouge ça veut dire
que soit c'est trop grand trop sucré
trop salé voyez pas assez de fibres etc
donc vous allez en consommer très peu
vous voyez et moi je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec votre approche il faut
informer le consommateur de deux choses
lui soit vous mettez deux paires de
lunettes pour regarder derrière le
paquet savoir la quantité de graisse la
quantité de sucre tout ça on n'a pas le
temps de le faire l'intérêt de nutriscor
c'est que c'est devant et en plus
contrairement à ce que vous dites on a
un comité scientifique qui regroupe les
six étapes que vous avez cités tout à
l'heure de par étape et ils font un
algorithme qui prennent en compte ce qui
a écrit derrière et il affiche devant et
moi je suis consommatrice je vais
comparer je vous parlais des biscuits
mais on pourrait parler des pizzas on
pourrait parler de plein de choses et là
dedans je vais choisir celui qui a le
meilleur note si par exemple je préfère
je veux manger du fromage ou de l'huile
je sais très bien que là on va plutôt
être vous voyez en dans les rouges ou
les oranges mais on en prend très peu
oui il faut pas lui faire dire ce qui ne
peut pas dire en tout cas les études
montrent que plus les gens vont sur le a
le B plus ça va inciter les industriels
à faire des recettes où on va moins
mettre de sel ou de sucre ou de gras et
que on va aller dans le bon sens et les
études montrent qu'il y a moins
d'obésité donc on est gagnant alors que
vous vous voulez pas informer le
consommateur et si vous voulez pas
informer le consommateur mais quand on a
une kyrielle de produits dans les
grandes surfaces on sait pas lequel
choisir et là c'est ça aide au choix non
mais c'est pas ça si je peux répondre
il y a un crimini criminalisation de
certains produits mais il y a et il y a
déjà aujourd'hui des produits qui
utilisent des alternatives au gras au
sucre au sel c'est c'est pas ça la
question de mettre un feu rouge c'est un
criminalisation au niveau de
l'algorithme on a déjà vu que
l'algorithme était pas bien fait parce
que personne n'achète une bouteille de
d'huile d'olive pour le boire comme ça
c'est une consommation très
très modeste et aussi le fromage pour la
pâte c'est
vous savez très bien que l'Italie a
proposé des alternatives qui font
considérer le régime alimentaire dans sa
complexité il faut utiliser de l'argent
public pour mieux informer les citoyens
et éliminaliser les produits parce que
les consommateurs
vous avez l'entrée vous avez
on raisonne par produit on est dans une
grande surface on valider le
consommateur à choisir le meilleur
produit par rapport à sa santé
le même produit peut avoir un effet plus
négatif pour moi mieux pour toi c'est
c'est une chose justement peut-être
monsieur camper qui est assez étonnant
c'est que
cette question du nutri-score il est
même intervenu lors de la campagne de de
Georgia Meloni c'était aussi un attribut
de souveraineté pour cette droite très à
droite etc pourquoi c'est tellement
sensible pour vous cette question au
point d'en faire un thème de campagne
politique en Italie soutient ça mon ami
des Castres il est un député européen de
groupe socialiste et il a un de plus de
plus informés sur ces choses-là qui qui
nous représente ce question là en Italie
je pense qu'il y a un soutien global
c'est pas George mais là on est même
jamais là dans l'autre législato n'était
même pas représenté avec son parti au
Parlement européen et ils étions nous et
les tendances
de la République tchèque la Roumanie etc
et les Italiens en plus on fait une
confusion entre voyez régime alimentaire
et produit déjà c'est une confusion et
puis après il y a République tchèque il
y a Chypre qui refuse parce que derrière
il y a le lobby agroalimentaire parce
qu'ils ont pas envie de changer leur
recette quand il y a beaucoup de sucre
c'est vrai que votre enfant va préférer
un biscuit très sucré qu'un biscuit
qu'il est qu'il est moins donc ils ont
poussé pour que des élus quel que soit
alors c'est typique de l'Italie quel que
soit leur étiquette politique qui sont
contre parce que oh là là ça va remettre
en question le régime méditerranéen mais
pas du tout moi je suis du sud de la
France je suis pour le régime
Méditerrané qui est très bon pour la
santé mais je choisis chaque produit
avec une étiquette vous voyez
la commission elle devait le décider fin
2022 on est en 2023 il y a toujours pas
de proposition sur la table parce que il
y a des pays qui bloquent mais si Michel
qui est vrai dans ce que dit Monsieur
campanoménosie l'algorithme il est en
train d'être modifié parce que oui il
avait été mal conçu quand même au départ
par exemple les boissons à édulcorant
les lights tous les lights qui n'ont pas
aujourd'hui on a découvert pas davantage
cruciaux sur sur les boissons normales
ou les papes plats préparés trop sucrés
trop salé les les céréales etc étaient
plutôt classé
A et c'était pas et c'était pas tout à
fait viable donc vous avez réussi une
évolution vous avez raison le comité
scientifique avec les critiques de
terrain ont modifié l'algorithme et par
exemple coca light qui était classé A
par rapport au coca qui contient
énormément de sucre ça vous le
reconnaissez que le coca contient
énormément de sucre et bien
il est plus classé à voyez il sera
classé dans le B ou le C donc c'est bien
parce que c'est un outil qui évolue et
vous pourriez si vous agréez le faire
évoluer
des produits alternatifs sans savoir
notre escort il y a beaucoup de choix
pour le consommateur mais on les a ses
choix avec des consommateurs mais les
consommateurs ne le comprennent pas vous
voyez votre nom
j'ai participé parce que nous notre
escort on a depuis 2017 en France donc
on a fait plein d'expérience dans les
grandes surfaces et on a vu que les gens
ne comprenaient pas cette étiquetage
parce que vous dites 20% de sel mais par
rapport à quoi 30% d'acides gras mais
par rapport à c'est c'est l'affichage
italien c'est ça
plus correcte parce que vous pensez que
le consommateur n'a pas la capacité de
décider n'a pas la connaissance
combien d'un produit il faut consommer
pour avoir un régime alimentaire
équilibré ça ça nous personne qui n'est
pas possible je pense que s'il y a des
consommateurs qui sont des problèmes
avec l'alimentation avec au sens un fort
rouge je
pense aussi attention qui s'il y a des
intérêts légitimes de producteurs
traditionnels pour les produits qu'ils
vont prendre le feu rouge il est aussi
des intérêts vous le savez très bien des
autres qu'ils vont remplacer les
produits traditionnels et qu'il pensait
que avec la notice fort ils peuvent
avoir des avantages mais l'Union
européenne justement elle était dans
dans cette dans cette la campagne et
puis depuis on dit elle nous protège pas
finalement le protège pas nos nos
savoir-faire mais elle a aussi les AOP
les les Appellations d'Origine Protégée
qu'elle qu'elle défend beaucoup et y
compris les Italiens il y en a beaucoup
donc peut-être que l'Union européenne
c'est pas si mal que ça pour
mais il faut mieux faire connaître les
appellations protégées parce que moi je
suis membre de la commission pour le
commerce international on travaille
beaucoup avec les pays tiers pour avoir
le respect des des filières productrices
comme ça mais la question c'est que la
question c'est la conscience
le consommateur peut faire peuvent
choisir avec des campagnes sur le régime
alimentaire ce que sur le faire active
sur marché sur
va changer avec le notre sport sinon
une concurrence déloyale entre les
entreprises de la transformation qui
joue avec la clinique les lasagnes
bolognaise qu'on peut trouver dans
certains
supermarché ici à Bruxelles c'est
quelque chose de pas très naturel mais
il joue avec la chimie elles peuvent
obtenir le jaune ou le verre aussi c'est
ça on prend les lasagnes nutri-score
vous paraît différents types de lasagnes
des lasagnes qui peuvent provenir
d'ailleurs de votre industrie en Italie
comme de France comme d'ailleurs et là
ils vont regarder quoi
c'est quoi la concentration au sucre on
sait on fibres elles sont pas italiennes
et elles sont pas bonnes voilà et mais
par contre elles sont nutriscors à il
est c'est la réponse quand même c'est
intéressant
[Musique]
même si vous avez une très bonne cuisine
c'est pas ça que je remets en question
mais moi je veux savoir si c'est il y a
beaucoup de gras il y a beaucoup de sel
parce que je sais que c'est une
conséquence sur la santé et alors ce que
je voudrais rajouter
ne peut pas tout dire et tout faire par
exemple moi qui suis écolo moi je suis
très sensible aux pesticides il faut
qu'il y ait nutri-score parce que c'est
nutritionnel vous voyez c'est c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure et puis il
faut qu'il y ait le label bio pour avoir
la garantie pas de pesticides vous me
parlez de la cuisine transformée vous
avez tout à fait raison que les produits
transformés on sait que ça peut
entraîner des cancers et bien ce qui est
demandé c'est qu'on rajoute vous voyez
autour du de l'étiquetage nutrisccor
quelque chose qui est noir et qui dit
que c'est
l'Union européenne elle devrait utiliser
son argent à faire des grandes campagnes
pour que les gens courent pour que les
gens mangent bien etc c'est votre c'est
votre
j'aurais besoin d'un régime alimentaire
plus équilibré je le connais très bien
mais mais moi je suis un consommateur
qui peut bien reconnaître qu'est-ce
qu'il va acheter il faut pas
criminaliser ce qu'il y a dans le
produit
l'avantage de l'éducation ça vous donne
des choses dans le produit il y a déjà
des informations le problème vous savez
bien le transport
nutrition
des choses nutritionnelles macro mais ne
considère pas les autres positifs qu'il
y a aussi dans des produits qu'ils ont
beaucoup de sel et sucre et gras que
nous savons nous savons très bien et
chacun un homme sportif peut consommer
la même chose avec moi limite que un
homme qui n'aime pas sportive moi par
exemple pour dans ce moment merci à vous
d'avoir été en notre compagnie sur
France 24 et Public Sénat à très bientôt
[Musique]